well that the situation was really
terrible the survivors were exhausted
they were heavily traumatized some of
them could not talk at all it was very
difficult to obtain any kind of
testimony is just a lot a lot of grief a
lot of desperation from others who had
see their children drown from children
who had seen their siblings drown in
their eyes very few children survived
only 13 very feared the women's arrived
around 20 of them and what we know from
other survivors is that there were many
many family units including many people
leaving more than from Syria and the
persecution from Eritrea and other
countries and of course a spotlight is
shining on Palermo tonight because of
this tragedy but it's a place that's
become quite used hasn't it two waves of
migrants coming across like this
yes I mean the figures are just simply
horrific there is 2,300 people that we
estimate have gone missing or died in
the Mediterranean this year alone and
just too by way of comparison last year
for the same period it was 1700 now last
year was already the deadliest year so
you know this year where there is an
incredible increase and this is a real
crisis which is happening in Europe as
definitely people drowning in the
Mediterranean in order to seek
protection and we've heard the mayor
there describing the situation as a
genocide caused by European selfishness
with unhcr agree with that
well what is what is you know yawns out
with the fact that people they're
fleeing for more in persecutions should
not have to put their lives in the hands
of smugglers in order to reach safety
and that's why UNHCR has appealing to
has been appealing to European states to
provide alternatives for people that are
fleeing from war so that they can enter
Europe safely it's not just because it's
a very difficult balancing act for
European governments because they say
they don't want to encourage migrants
economic migrants come across or how do
they get the balance right what should
they do
well okay so let's let's talk about the
fact the you know the main nationality
of people arriving by sea in the
Mediterranean right now is Syrians
followed by our trends and people from
Afghanistan possibly are also refugees
so really there needs to be a shift in
policy from border control to you know
thinking that this is a refugee crisis
in a Mediterranean and that you know it
is not about pull factors but it is
about the sheer desperation of people
that have no other way I mean of course
no mother wants to risk her her
children's lives on on an overcrowded
boat on a fishing boat with 600 people
nobody would do that if they were not
leaving behind something which is far
worse and what about the rescue
operation itself because we know that
Europe has poured more resources into
that but what we saw yesterday was that
horrific situation with possibly
hundreds of lives lost are there enough
resources
well of course yes I mean this this just
demonstrates this episode demonstrate
that you know even though the rear there
is a rescue operation and even though
the rescue boss was actually reached you
know a few miles off of north of Libya
the boat that was in distress the
problem is that you know the smugglers
are filling the boats beyond capacity
and mean as I said it's a fishing boat
with 600 people at which hundreds are
trapped in the Hall of the boat and
never even had a chance to get out while
it was sinking you know the conditions
are horrific and even with the best
search-and-rescue operation it's just
you know there they are literally
accidents waiting to happen you know
this is why what's really going to
prevent that is to provide people with
alternatives really awful situation in
Baltimore linaria really appreciate you
taking the time out to talk to us
tonight thank you